tu t'appelles tu t'appelles comment un
appui de taille et comment
tatelier tout ça est ce que tu habites
ta taille est avec toi
oui d'accord mais où est-ce que j'habite
moi je suis comment tu sais pas je suis
toujours dans une caisse quand tu
rentres à la maison
dis moi ta taille et tu vas à l'école
pourquoi je suis tu
qu'est ce que tu fais alors toute la
journée rien rien du tout tu t'en met
pas la taille est taillée
il ya quelque chose qui te fait plaisir
1 oui quoi que tu une fiche la paix avec
ta question à la caisse
recevant l'as à sémalens ta taille et tu
te goures et là moi je me suis gouré
oui thani sémalens tatayet mais c'est
normal je suis ventriloque qui connaît
là je parle sans remuer les lèvres
vingt six saynètes a tenu sa tombe au
championnat comme en nos noms aussi un
jeu temps sans renier les lèvres oui
mais moi je parle avec ta voix et et moi
je parle avec la tienne et sans remuer
les lèvres inventions qui coule
- marionnettes alors comment ce qu'est
ce que tu veux faire avec ça comme toi
mais tu peux pas te tailler minutes
bon elle m'a il y en a une dans tabouret
si tu veux qu'est ce qu'une sous la dent
c'est moi qu'il y ait misé avant le
spectacle parce que je savais bien que
tu allais m'en demander une et je me
sens inutile ya dix mois
oui mais voilà six mois que j'écris le
sketch
qu'est-ce que celle instruite us cake tu
veux savoir avant de le jouer
bon eh bien tu vas descendre de mon
genou
oui tu vas te mettre debout sur le
tabouret tu vas dire que tu as l'air con
et puis tu y vas prendre la marionnette
tu sais ta taille et je te fais faire et
je te fais dire ce que je veux un
tiens par exemple je t'aime je t'aime
j'étais je te déteste
allez je te déteste je ne suis qu'une
marionnette sans cervelle je ne suis qu
il n'a rien eu de censure que je
n'existe pas rec
c'est moi du centre sur le temps vous
voulez aller d'accord je l'air con tu
vas prendre la marionnette à ces
tranches de vie ma gueule chérie
dépêche toi ok sinon j'ai pas lu les
raids
oui mais il faut la manipuler aussi en
commun ça tu lui mets la main dans la
tête la ctq
c'est le seul moyen ça y est je trouve
ta les trous des peintres avaient tutoyé
1,20 à les concevoir
il ta taille et il est tout petit il
faut lui parler avec beaucoup de douceur
un hockey n'a convaincu qu'il est le
gros chien chien c'est un gentil qu'on a
ça dans le sang
c'est un magnifique via une issue qui
joue qui avoue qu'il est gentil à vous
dit ça y est j ventriloque mêlant
d'initiés dont la première fois la
télévision
je vais faire chanter nos marionnettes
j'en prends les gens très un jacques
barney vous dormez vous qu'est ce que
c'est la suite j'ai pas j'ai retrouvé ma
relate en 100 minutes chine tu connais
non non c'est moi qui viens de me
souvenir et j'ai moi entre irakiens
on est chez moi qui chante ta taille et
tout le monde sait bien que vous fait
parlé tous les deux chefs ont figé qui
conduisit c'est moi ta taille et mais
non mais non mais non mais non mais non
mais non mais non mais non